- All right, everybody,
(applause)
I'm back with Jake Hoot, give it up!
(cheering)
All right, well, everybody,
we have seen and been horrified
by the violence against Asian
Americans in our country.
I've always said I wanted this show
to be a safe place to discuss anything,
even the tough stuff,
I think it's important,
which is one of the
reasons why I'm honored
to introduce my next guest.
She is an incredibly talented
musician and advocate
who is using her powerful voice
to in part express her
emotional experience
being Asian in America.
You saw her perform at the
Women's March four years ago,
and she recently collaborated
with poet Amanda Gorman,
who was also on our show.
Please welcome MILCK, everybody!
(bright music)
Meet Jake, MILCK!
- [Jake] Hi!
- Hi!
Hi, Jake,
Hi, Kelly.
- Hello!
But MILCK, you've spoken
out against the recent rise
in Asian hate crime,
and you say music has
helped you through this.
I believe music helps people through,
you know, the majority of things,
I just think it's very
moving and inspiring,
but why personally for you?
- I grew up using music
as a place of freedom.
I think, you know, I'm a
huge fan of what you do
and how you sing and how you
bring your own story into it,
and I don't need to be Asian
enough or American enough
or you know, cool enough in music,
I can just be whoever I am truly,
and songwriting helps
me explore the topics
that are difficult to
feel in a (snaps) flash.
I remember hearing this quote.
"A woman who can sing is
never caged and always free."
So processing the difficult
and painful moment
after the Atlanta
shootings and the increase,
you know, 150% increase of hate crimes
in the US for Asian American hate crimes,
this music helps me to put that in a place
where I can alchemize it
and turn that fear or that
pain into power and purpose,
into love, that's my hope.
- I mean, it's so funny,
'cause I feel like I'm in Nashville,
and we're like writers
in the round right now,
'cause there's three writers
sitting here right now.
(Jake laughs)
And how you just
described how you write is
how I write with my own life,
and I'm sure that's what you do.
- Absolutely, that's the
beauty of songwriting.
- Yeah, it's so therapeutic,
and I love the part that you said
I process like that too.
I can't, I don't like, like, you know
when you're like talking with
someone and you're like, look
I need to step away.
Cause I don't know exactly
all my thoughts on this.
So I just need a minute
and I go away and writing is
actually very helpful for that.
And I think, you know, also, you know
you being such an advocate
for these important messages
I think it's important to
use your voice for that.
And your, your writing and it's important
for you to process that
and you experience that.
So it's, you know what I'm saying?
It's people are, it's more believable.
- Yes.
- It's authentic.
It's, it's a beautiful thing.
I think as well, like we've
talked about gender equality
on the show too, and I
think it ties into, you know
it can't just be females in that march.
It needs to be men too.
There needs to be men there
in order for actual change to happen.
And also it can't just be Asians.
There needs to be a diverse group walking
and marching saying this isn't wrong
because that's the whole point I feel is
that nothing's going to change
unless everybody decides to wake up
and see the issue in order
for that progress to happen.
So I want to talk about your song.
Somebody is beloved.
So I think I know
but can you tell everybody,
you know, what inspired it?
- Yes, absolutely.
I wrote this song with
an incredible artist
Bipolar Sunshine.
This song is inspired by the bravery
and power that I see with
Tamika Palmer when she speaks
about her daughter, Breonna Taylor.
And I, I feel like sometimes the
the topics can feel really complicated
but when I zone into the one
human life, cause you know
we all have been seeing huge numbers of
of deaths and stuff.
It's hard.
And I was like, I think
I'm becoming desensitized
and I need to just honor a life.
And my hope is, you know
to bring solidarity between
different communities
to acknowledge the pain
that we have passed on
to each other and, and find
ways to move forward together.
And so, you know, we call this
like a black and gold
conversation coming together
with black and Asian communities.
And I think that's really
important right now.
And we can be better advocates
for a longer period of time
if we bring the conversation
to a heart space.
- [Kelly] Agreed. I agree.
Everything from love, speak from love.
I, I agree.